thank you so much for being on the
program firstly how was your meeting
with emmanuel macron and are you
satisfied with what he said to you
um
well good morning also we do not say
good morning anymore in ukraine
but yeah it is very important for us now
to give personal uh you know evidence
and what is going on in kiev in kharkiv
in other cities we did have a meeting
with uh macron and we were four members
of parliament and women battalion which
we call ourselves now and also a mayor
of melitopol
uh who was captured and who was uh taken
hostage for six days and then was
exchanged for nine russian soldiers so
he he told his experience in being in
captivity uh how host was he treated
what did they want how he was forced to
resign obviously he did not resign and i
think it was incredibly important for
french people for french politicians and
for the french president to hear and to
hear it from somebody who is not resume
but who's been there two days ago just
there in kiev
as to how successful it was
uh well we will see obviously on the
results um we you know we ukraine is
pretty much done with diplomacy we have
been very straightforward we have been
very direct and i will tell you very
honestly if something that macron
promised he did not deliver
but i hope that he will deliver on every
point that we talked about
and i'm very keen to talk about the
individual stories of what's happening
in ukraine but just firstly on macron um
europe and the eu is of course spending
hundreds of millions of pounds every day
on russian
oil and particularly gas
is that acceptable
no it's not acceptable and actually that
question was raised obviously with
president macron and he said that yes
they are ready to do an embargo on
russian oil and gas
they have denied paying in rubles
for it as you know uh as did a lot of
other members of the european union and
we asked macron specifically as a
president or right now as he is the
president of france's presidency in
europe to work with other countries uh
and to work on the unity basically
because if the europe will not be united
then putin will for sure become stronger
and stronger and we do need to stop the
putin together today and together uh
that is why it was very important to
talk to france after actually our visit
to great britain as you may know
just to clarify president macron told
you that he was prepared to do an
embargo on russian
oil and gas
he said that he's prepared yes to go
through if would be needed yes
and do you believe him do you believe
his assurance
um well yesterday we were also you know
at the manifestation because ukrainians
and french people gather in paris in the
plaza de la republique every saturday
for the manifestations to actually put a
pressure on french politicians to stop
buying russian gas to stop buying
russian oil uh to stop putting russian
cargo ships uh to the french ports
uh and and basically to force the
companies which are french companies to
go outside of russia and i think that
this pressure is the main important
pressure why it will work so i'm sure
that actually those manifestations those
meetings um those hundreds of thousands
of people that go every saturday they
are the ones who actually will force it
through till the end
and this is why i am much more
optimistic
you are mentioned there that you were
joined by the mayor who was captured by
russian forces i think many of us will
remember
that story of them taking the mayor and
what exactly did happen to him and how
was he treated
oh
it's obviously better to ask him but
yeah his story is incredible because
well basically he he had the possibility
to communicate was the one who captured
him right so he had the possibility to
ask some questions and to get the
answers because he was there for a while
basically what they wanted from him they
wanted him to resign uh or to
collaborate with them or to appoint a
deputy mayor that would be from the
russian soldier's side and obviously he
did not do that um as far as i
understand they were too scared to
actually kill him or torture him because
his case got to the very highest level
and putting knew about his case
personally
but he's saying that he was asking them
all the time why did you come to my city
and why do you want to do that and the
answers he got were
well incredible from the russian
propaganda side because they would say
that you know
we want to liberate you from the nazi
regime and he was like well i'm 33 years
old i have never seen one nothing in
ukraine what else and they would say
well we know that you uh kill and bully
veterans of the second world war on the
streets and he would be like well there
are 34 veterans alive of the second
world war in my city milital and i am in
constant contact with them and bring
them food you know and then and medicine
and anything they need so this kind of
propaganda talks who have been going for
days and he was trying to as i
understand
well convince them on something but it
was it was an incredible thing how the
russian soldiers at the time were you
know propaganda brainwashed and what did
they think would happen
you say that they were too scared to
kill him or to torture or harm him
of course that is not something that is
afforded to so many of the ukrainian
civilians and this morning we've seen
what has been left after russian forces
retreated from areas around kiev
can you just explain to our viewers the
kind of things that people of ukraine
are witnessing
um well right now unfortunately we have
another city which has been uh destroyed
as mario paul was it's called izum uh in
translation from ukraine from ukrainian
it's raisin so it's supposed to be
something you know
nice and and and and
well and food-like but there is no food
right now in in raisin or in zoom uh
it's been destroyed by 80 percent uh i
think it's becoming the next mario ball
which is a horrifying news for us to
hear it's also in the east of ukraine
there is no food
people have been forced well to stay
underground without food and water as
mario paul were people are not being
able to escape
and basically this humanitarian
catastrophe is that putin is putting on
ukraine continues
we actually did raise a number of
questions
about the international red cross
because you know that the presence of
international red cross was not there on
the ground in those horrible situations
to help people
uh we want either red cross to be much
more present either we want to recross
to make a statement why they are not
present because personally in personal
conversations they say that russia is
not allowing them to be present and is
not accepting their diplomatic immunity
but they are not making a public
statement about that and this is
something which is horribly wrong with
international law and with international
order
so i really hope that international red
cross would go more public
and would be much more helpful for the
people who are there who are in the
worst possible situation right now in
the middle of europe three hours from us
right now
not having food not having water not
knowing whether they would be alive
tomorrow
living in horrible in in absolutely
horrible conditions of fear pain no
medicine nothing delivered and not being
able to go you know to another city in
ukraine and this is something which is
shocking for me even on the 39 days of
war i still i still don't get how did we
allow this to happen
it's horrific situation people just as
you say trapped with no food no water
in the worst possible situation thank
you so much for coming on the program we
value your voice and thank you
thank you thank you